I was a kid my stepfather yeah used to
accuse me of [__] like somebody stole
the 50 cents off the thing that I go why
would I take a [__] a 50 cent piece
off a [__] thing I got money he got
to me so much that I would see where he
would hide his book making money and he
was a slick [__] let's do it
with the rubber bands a piece of his
hair he would do [__] for the marking on
the top of the bill so I didn't want to
steal from it but I wanted to give him a
[__] taste of what he put me through
so I would switch the money around
so I would say Phil got the hair in it I
wouldn't even open it I would take the
five thousand dollar bundle and then I
would take the 10 grand bundle and
switch it with his attorney fund he
believes that he's losing his mind and I
would see him looking at the money and
go
hahaha